[Music]
everyone
III 2018 has started I'm Randy this is
alessandro of the very first game we
played is anthem from Bioware now I
actually didn't get to play it I just
saw behind-closed-doors presentation you
actually got to play it and I guess the
thing is this is a game from Bioware who
is a developer that is known for its
narrative led games but it kinda doesn't
feel like a like a story focused game
right now right like because what you
saw was action yeah this is this feels
very much in the vein of like destiny or
the division yeah it's that sort of
shared world online shooter where you
can team up with like other players like
you know go on missions like you know
level up game loot and I at first I
thought it was a little off-putting
because I'm used to that sort of like
traditional Bioware experience where you
you create a character you make choices
you you go through like this sort of
epic quest and while that's still there
it this is sort of more focused on like
that sort of shooting and like
action-oriented experience and I
actually thought that was a good thing
for a change and to be clear like the
section you played I think is the stuff
they showed at the at the press
conference the PDA which is yeah you're
standing and you start in your you know
in your Forward Operating Base you get
into your Colossus um we played on the
Ranger oh okay cool yeah because yeah
yeah and then you go at and a lot of it
that demo was basically traversal right
like moving around the world and
eventually ending up and then big bug
monster yes yeah the thing that you know
was interesting to me was just sort of
that how different it felt I guess from
not only just for Bioware game but just
also like even from destiny or the
division where you know there's just a
greater focus on like verticality yeah
like a you know I can you can quote me
on this but I can say that this is the
best Iron Man game will ever get I know
yeah some of that range is moving as
those like small missiles pop out from
his from his armor look there you are
and man yeah this is totally Iron Man
you know and I've what I felt most
affected by this game was that uh you
know the shooting just in the general
action of it just melts so punchy and
like felt really sharp and I think that
was sort of years are just sort of
experience on even like Mass Effect
series where they were just sort of
refining slowly but slowly refining that
you know sort of the mechanics of it and
this to me just feels like you know the
best they've ever had in terms like
action-oriented game so you feel like
they built up those skills in
third-person action over the last few
massive eight games and it feels it
feels like a proper action game it does
you know which is weird because this is
Bioware because like you know they sort
of like they're they focus on what
they're good at which is storytelling
like you know RPG traditional RPG
gameplay but now they're just sort of
they're basically showing what they've
got when it comes to action gameplay
which is really which is really really
impressive so how did the range or
actual feel like to play because yeah as
we mentioned the Colossus was the one
they showed off quite a lot in in the
gameplay revealed today but how did the
Ranger actually play well when you look
at it sort of the lineup of like all the
javelins you know they sort of follow
those you know traditional like RPG like
archetypes that's one of the DPS slaying
the tank the blast cannon mage and like
the Interceptor which we didn't get to
see at all but uh which sort of feels
similar to like a rogue but the Ranger
is very much that sort of all around
like you know DPS or into class and he
has to the skills we had were the sort
of the legendary skill called the frost
grenade and also a concussive blast
attack which you know sort of pushes
back enemies and the interesting thing
about you know what this game does is
that it focuses on sort of using combo
attacks with other javelins so if you
use a frost grenade on you know a group
of enemies and freeze them in place you
can have the Colossus you know rein in
like you know rockets and stuff and
it'll create extra damage and you'll see
like those like yeah bonus yeah yeah
they also mentioned verticality and I
guess you know that was one of my key
you know like fears like you know before
I saw a lot of our manthang game there
was it yet it looked kind of similar to
you know to something like destiny yeah
but it you know because I have you know
such a verticality you know inherent in
the actual javelins it seems like it's
gonna be very different
like did you actually use that a lot in
your gameplay like we're actually
flying around taking on enemies how did
that feel it felt great and you know we
use it a lot actually and it will in a
lot of ways it's sort of like sprinting
like you know just how you know used to
you know like how tight it is to like
sort of general locomotion of the
gameplay and we didn't get to see how
far like high up you can fly but you can
actually you know travel around like you
know through the air like you know
through you know significant distance
and it does have like sort of a sort of
overheat mechanic but what we saw during
the presentation and also what I
experienced in my play session was that
if you go through waterfalls and you'll
instantly recharge like you know you're
sort of a fuel meter so it is gated by
meter you can't you can't just
indefinitely float and just like zoom
around or any because you will
eventually have to get on the ground now
we talked a lot about the action and you
know I I know that you know story wasn't
really a focus of what they show today
but boy I did say that you know this is
still a Bioware game that there is still
gonna be a lot of narrative in this but
right now it seems kind of unclear right
that's do you know how that fits in it
seems like from what I can gather anyway
like all of them all of the actual story
happens in your own personal instance of
the world like you know in your base
that that's where story gets progressed
as we have found out about stuff and
then the actual the actual sort of open
world itself is where missions where the
action actually takes place is that is
that the sense you got from that as well
definitely
well I even spoke with Mark Dora you
know after you know we got to play and
you know I got the sense that you know
the sort of the the story is much more
of a nebulous concept than anthem yeah
because you know you do have your
moments of where you tell your story
within you know the f OB which is like
when all Story cutscenes and like you
know those sort those moments are
actually within the first-person so you
know those are like sort of those
personal moments basically but how that
ties into the larger open-world you know
with other players like making their own
unique choices is still unclear but um I
do like you know the sort of setting and
you're sort of the vibe of it you know
so I'm really interested in seeing how
they're able to sort of blend that
together yeah and it seems they're you
know they're really trying to you know
shoot for the stars here because you
know I think in their presentation
I mentioned that you know they've built
this narrative so that it can be
continually expanded upon and you know I
think they've already started sort of
talking slightly about some of the plans
they have post release for them for this
game so it's a big undertaking and you
know they're in it for the long haul yes
they're definitely in it for the long
haul yeah so overall impressions of
anthem you like what you play today you
do you want to you know excited to find
out more
I loved it a lot more than I thought I
would like it definitely like um because
I feel like you know the sort of concept
of like the shared world online shooter
is really common like you know we and
we've been playing destiny for a few
years now and the division which is you
know has shown considerable growth so
I'm interested in seeing just how
expansive this one is because I feel
like the verticality of this game just
just really adds its own flavor to it
and it really does set itself apart from
the other games that I played yeah we
gotta wait a little ball for it though
because I think it's February 2019
twenty-second if every 22nd 2019 so
that's it for anthem at this year's e3
check out GameSpot for more on that game
and heaps others
[Music]
[Music]